my guest tonight is a very funny
comedian and one of the most talented
impressionists performing today uh she's
also
the first ever latina cast member on
saturn out live
please welcome the insanely talented
melissa
via senor melissa thanks for doing this
thanks conan
thanks for having me we have a lot to
talk about i am
i've been wanting to talk to you for a
while uh you've been obviously killing
it
on sign out live you're so funny uh
you do such amazing impressions the
latest i'm told is lin-manuel miranda
you're working on a lin-manuel miranda
this is you in your uh
in your makeup as lin-manuel miranda and
if i'm not mistaken you just took a
ballpoint pen
is that what you did well no no no that
that is an eyeliner
and i i always know that it looks really
good i mean it doesn't look realistic
but i'm saying
that's what that's all i had on me okay
okay okay
no i i like it i'm just gonna tell you
in real life
and you probably have to i've i've spent
time with lin-manuel miranda and in real
life he uses a ballpoint pen
oh okay so that's what he does and he
just fills it in throughout the day
what is the key to i don't know that
i've heard someone do
a lin manuel miranda impression what's
the key how do you hone in on that
well i i was thinking about it the way
he's
he sings it sounds like he's in the sea
and he's drowning
okay and he's telling a boat nearby he's
saying please
have me a lifesaver i'm drowning i just
want to live
with you and so that's all
right or he's slipping off a a um
a rope maybe no i i love you
don't let go
[Laughter]
do you sing some of the actual songs
that he sings in hamilton
i i i have been singing my shot but the
problem is i don't know
all the lyrics but i want to sing it
real fast like he does
right and i was trying to sing it to my
sister the other day i was like
i am not throwing away my shot i am not
throwing away my
shot and you're just like my country i'm
young scruffy and homie and i said homie
and me i'm hungry it's hungry it's
hungry
have you tried this out on lin-manuel
miranda um
nobody saw i i shared a photo of that oh
no the video of me
i went to i drove through a uh a coffee
place and i said i'll take a
cold brew with a shot and i filmed it
was so stupid
but he he messaged me and he laughed so
those are my favorite
my favorite impressions are the silly
ones do you know what i mean
yeah which just like you're using it in
a completely ridiculous absurd way
getting uh getting a starboard starbucks
order
you also do um i'm a huge fan of john
mullaney's
as as as i think we all are but you do a
great john mulaney impression
i think for him i was just kind of
i think i watched his stand-ups a few
specials and i was thinking of like he
always goes i've noticed
when i wear my pants sometimes i do have
ants in
my pants and that's a saying but it's
true to my
life it's always saying like i noticed
something
uh an observation
and then uh he's got kind of an old
fashioned
uh sort of diction and i mean he could
be in vaudeville it could be 1922 when
he has john mullaney you know
he saw it on on the snl at home
he was in the master class sketch where
he's a master
at at putting on suits putting together
your tie
and your butt and look like you're going
to your first holy communion
and so he saw it and he really liked it
and i
noticed he does a certain thing when
he's walking goes
you know you know what one of the
impressions that
you do i'm just talking about how you'll
pick an unusual target
the little rascals the little rascals is
something that i grew up watching and
it's from the 1930s but they would show
it a lot on local television when i was
a kid
that's how i know it i didn't even know
that someone your age would be aware of
the little rascals
we would rent the little rascals vhs the
classics
oh good okay but the past few months my
mom
just let me borrow her little rascal
dvds and she said give them back
because these are my favorite i'm not
going to keep them
no yeah and so you learned you started
watching those and i'm told you do a
little rascal's impression or an
impression of a little
of the little rascals well because i i
was trying to watch
little rascals and i couldn't even get
through an episode i don't know what
they're saying
you can't hear it it's so crinkly and
old you know
they're just like he's got his heartbeat
how do you want his wall
no hamburger
that's all i can hear so yeah that's
pretty much all it is and also
long takes they'll do like there'll be
visuals of like spanky looking
or alfalfa looking at something or
somebody a buckwheat
they'll just be looking at something and
they'll be like
and the camera will be on them way too
long and you think
they just had more time in the 19th
you know comedy but it's like this and
back then
someone would do something funny and
they'd cut to someone else going
yeah you're like what you just had more
time during the
was depression film expensive then uh
owen wilson owen wilson people do
impressions of i'm told you do uh
you do a pretty me now in wilson i do
yeah i learned that when
probably over 10 years ago i remember
trying it out at the haha cafe open mic
when i was 17. no one knew who he was in
the crowd they were like who's owen
and i was ahead of the time owen wilson
knows that you do an impression of him
right yeah
three years ago my dad met him at a
a job site my dad's offense contractor
if you need if you need a gate
conan you let me know and i'll let my
dad know
sure i would i would be honored to have
your dad build me a gate
just picturing a gate around you yeah i
want a gate surrounding i want a gate
that separates myself
from my son
from my 14 year old son yeah my my dad
was working
at a house in malibu okay putting up a
gate and he sees owen walk by
and he goes hey owen i'm melissa
viesner's dad she does an impression of
you
and then owen goes oh yeah i've seen you
it's pretty good yeah
wow it's very good and then they were
chatting for a while
and then at the end of the conversation
my dad goes hey owen be careful over
there okay
because there's a beehive just watch out
and owen goes okay
thanks yeah and then
uh three years later i meet owen and i
go oh and
i love you so much oh man nice to meet
you and then the first thing he says
is i met your dad
he helped me out with some bees
you've helped me out with some bees yes
exactly i love that if you hadn't known
what he was talking about that would
have been so funny
yeah god hadn't told you and you met
owen
if i met owen wilson and he just said
yeah i met your dad he helped me out
with some bees
i'd be i would love it i would love not
knowing the context
a lot of joy you talk about your doubt
are your parents funny did you get your
sense of humor from your parents
yeah i i did um my dad
is the goofy one the people pleaser he's
sensitive he loves musicals
my mom is like the honest uh
just you know sometimes she's just
brutally honest you know sometimes
she'll look at me and she'll go like
your mustache is coming in take care of
that you're on a show now
so there's you know but they're so
different they're kind of like um
i share this on stage they're they're
like you know planes trains and animal
bills
yeah i see i know i watch all the
classics okay good for me
good for you i was you got to give me a
chance to say good for you
you got to give someone a chance all
right all right by the way i give to
charities and that makes me a great guy
but anyway so yeah the classic steve
martin john candy
planes trains yeah so on our vhs cover
in the 90s my dad
wrote his name next to john candy's
character and my mom
next to steve martin okay and so
they have arguments like in the movie
i've heard them in their room like my
mom would be like mike
not everyone needs to like you okay
people don't like me i'm okay with that
you don't see me crying
my dad's like stop it loopy okay the
kids were having a tough week i was
trying to make them laugh
they don't like you mike nobody likes
you
and i walk in like mom and dad are you
guys okay my mom's like i'm okay
your dad's crying nobody likes him
but he like gets upset when he when when
someone dislikes him and he wants to fix
it
i identify with your dad and i don't
think i could stand
uh i mean that's br that's rough first
of all your mom doesn't sound like she's
being brutally honest i'm sure there are
people who like your dad
nobody likes you
that's not honest that's just that's
cruel you don't say that to anybody
i mean sometimes when he's you know a
little little geeky or something my mom
will be like you know
if i knew you in school i'd beat you up
well
i it sounds like a very loving
relationship it's
it's very it's really it balances out
it's pretty fun
it's also you got to have parents like
that to get you into comedy
that's the reason to do it you know yeah
and i think i'm like that i think i'm
silly but i could also be
pretty pissed and and honest
really yes okay are you mad at me now
okay i'm i'm actually i don't want you
mad at me so i'll just you know
i'll do my i'll do my best to behave um
stand up i know i'm impressed by this
because
during the pandemic so many stand-up
comedians are saying well i can't work i
can't go to a club you've been picking
some really
unusual venues you've been doing
stand-up we have a picture here of you
on a porch
where is this is this uh l.a or where
are you
that it was somewhere near usc i
think you're usc yeah but i was
crap crowd looks uh well i can't really
i can't tell if you're bombing there or
what you can't tell what's happening
it was okay it was okay uh-huh it was a
a lady a nurse who works at cedars
i she i she reached out and i
you know i said i would perform it for
front lawn and those were a few of her
neighbors that came by
that's nice i bought yes i bought a
little speaker and
and a microphone from guitar center and
i said let's
do this and i went i told i i performed
at a
baseball park once um
in a tree house oh yeah we have a
picture
what's happening here because here you
are in a tree house before
again i can't tell how it's going over
but this is like a slightly
better venue to me so this was this was
great
because two things performing in a tree
house
brought the kid energy even more alive
in my jokes
you know and uh and then uh that height
level
you know being above so high gave me a
lot of power
right yeah you you look like you could
be a stand-up or a uh
a dictator you look like you could be a
a cruel arbitrary dictator who works
with a little
is that a is that a little girl you're
you're doing
who is who is your co-star in this oh
that now that was
so my friend cindy that's her daughter
leona and that's her
leona's tree house so she was of course
like who's this person up here in my
treehouse
so she stood by me like a little
bodyguard
[Laughter]
he looks like your hype man you know
just there to like oh yep uh-huh
that's right preach tell it that looks
like fun though
it was really that was my favorite that
was so fun so when do you guys
uh i want to make sure i get the word
out because you start up again uh
start out live returns october 3rd
october 3rd
yeah at 11 30 on nbc
uh melissa thank you so much it really
is
it really is a joy to talk to you and um
congratulations
on everything it's uh thanks conan yeah
seriously can i call you conan or
are we on
melissa thank you so much and take care
you too